SARAH PRICE: Hi, Glass
developers.
Welcome to 2013.
I'm Sarah Price, your
community advocate.
I've been reading all of your
comments and questions online,
and I've noticed maybe one or
two questions about what it's
going to be like to
develop for Glass.
You want to know what
the API is like.
You want to know what languages
you can use.
You know what I mean.
So to help answer those
questions, I want to introduce
you today to some members of our
developer relations team,
Jenny and Timothy.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi, I'm Jenny,
and I'm a Glass Developer
Programs Engineer.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I'm
Timothy Jordan.
I'm a Glass Developer
Advocate.
SARAH PRICE: So Jenny, can you
tell us a little bit about
what it's going to be like
to develop for Glass?
JENNY MURPHY: Absolutely.
Development on Glass is done
with something called the
Mirror API, and it's basically
a collection
of RESTful web services.
One of the great parts about
this is if you've done any
development with other web
services at Google, you'll
feel right at home developing
on Glass.
SARAH PRICE: So I'm actually not
very familiar with RESTful
web services.
What kinds of languages could
I use to develop using them?
JENNY MURPHY: That's one of the
great parts about RESTful
web services.
They're inherently
language-independent, so you
can develop with whatever tools
or languages are your
favorite, whether that be PHP
or Python or even Java.
SARAH PRICE: Well, the next
question I've seen a lot is,
when are people going
to get access?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, that's
something that we're excited
to announce today.
For developers in the Glass
Explorer program, we're
putting together what we
call the Glass Foundry.
You can think of it as kind
of a vacation with Glass.
For two full days, in San
Francisco or New York, you'll
get early access to Glass
and the Mirror API.
It's going to be a lot of fun,
and we'll send an invite out
to your email shortly.
Space is limited, so please
sign up right away.
SARAH PRICE: Well, thanks
so much, guys.
I've seen so many great
suggestions from developers
for what you want to
do with Glass.
I can't wait to see what
they put together.
So thanks, and see you
at the Glass Foundry.